aujourd'hui on est là pour parler d'eux
au nord est de microsoft pourquoi parce
que vous avez ici le honor magic book 14
je voulais déjà présenté jeu déjà me
montels d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas vu
vous invite à venir découvrir mon test
c'est un ordinateur qui est vraiment
idéal pour je dirais des étudiants des
jeunes actifs qui veulent un ordinateur
pas forcément cher suffisamment puissant
et avec lequel vous allez pouvoir faire
plein de choses par rapport à la
productivité puisque la productivité
c'est un élément essentiel lorsqu'on
souhaite travailler faire la prise de
notes même gérer ses comptes au
quotidien faire ces courriers enfin on a
besoin d'un ordinateur comme ça pour
faire la productivité de façon
personnelle voire même professionnel je
vais donc vous montrer aujourd'hui
comment fonctionne le magic book 14,2 au
nord avec microsoft 365 mais avant toute
chose si ce n'est pas déjà fait vous
invite à vous abonner pourquoi parce que
je parle beaucoup de technologies goethe
est effectivement des ordinateurs des
monts compte des smartphones je vous
parle de votre vie numérique je vous
donne plein de bons conseils pleins de
bonnes astuces pour réussir tout ça donc
vous cliquez sur le bouton qui situent
juste ici en dessous van dessel là juste
là vous cliquez vous y allez vous
activer la cloche comme ça vous serez
notifié et vous saurez tout des qui aura
une nouvelle vidéo qui sortira
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui a réalisé en
partenariat avec honor pour vous parler
d'un pack spécial aux normes indique
bout 14 pouces avec inclut un abonnement
de un an à microsoft 365 à cette
occasion au nord a organisé un défi
looking up 'future' qui viennent
traduire littéralement un regard dans
l'avenir l'idée c'est que vous puissiez
remporté cette jolie petite machine pour
participer il faut que vous créiez une
oeuvre qui symbolise notre objectif de
vie post déconfinement ça peut-être de
deux formes différentes soit sous la
forme d'une illustration soit sous la
forme d'une vidéo votre création doit
être en accord avec la marque avec honor
une image donc fun et dynamique vous
pouvez poster vos créations à partir du
29 juin et vous avez jusqu'au 15 juillet
à 23h59 c'est extrêmement précis pour
participer et les finalistes seront
annoncés
21 juillet y aura donc un jury qui sera
composé de designers professionnels
également de créateurs orienté tech dont
je ferai partie
en tout il y aura deux magic books a
gagné ce prix c'est le honor master
world également votre oeuvre affichée
pendant trois jours sur la page
d'accueil ayo nord votre offre également
affiché dans l'album officiel du
concours
le deuxième prix c'est au nord créative
walla y aura trois gagnants vous
gagnerez une au nord magic watch deux et
vous aurez également votre offre qui
sera affichée dans l'album officiel du
concours troisième prix c'est le au nord
broyage award
voyez un peu le truc et vous gagnerez
une paire d'écouteurs magic est un mode
plus votre qui sera bien évidemment
afficher dans l'album celle du concours
et là il y aura cinq gagnants il y aura
donc en tout dix gagnants je vous laisse
participer envoyer vos créations à
partir du 29 juin prochain
et croyez moi croyez moi j'ai vraiment
hâte de les découvrir je vais pas vous
reparler en long en large et en travers
du aux normes hadji de bouc parce que
j'ai déjà fait j'invite donc une fois de
plus à aller voir ma vidéo liés à ce
produit là d'ailleurs est ce que vous
l'avez acheté est ce que c'est un
produit qui vous intéressent que c'est
un produit qui vous a intéressé marc
coma ça tout de suite
en bas on commentait alors on va
commencer tout de suite a parlé de
microsoft 365 avant ça s'appelait office
il ya eu un changement nous on appelle
ça le naming maintenance et microsoft
165 mais ça inclut la suite que vous
connaissiez très probablement word excel
powerpoint outlook et à skype guen
évidemment onenote et one drive vous
avez un terrain de stockage inclus dans
le code
alors ici on va faire un focus sur la
productivité il ya plein de nouveaux
outils qui sont arrivés avec microsoft
165 il ya des mises à jour j'ai pas si
vous êtes des jeunes utilisateurs
d'office c'est un outil que j'utilise au
quotidien
le premier outils que j'utilise ces
world parce que ward il est extrêmement
pratique je vais pas vous faire un topo
de worth pense que vous connaissez mais
il ya une nouveauté a été mis en place
cette année par microsoft et microsoft
editor alors microsoft editor c'est tout
simplement l'éditeur de texte que vous
allez pouvoir retrouver aussi bien dans
word dans excel mais également plugins
dans microsoft edge navigateur ou alors
même en plug in dans google chrome est
ce que ça va vous permettre de faire
c'est là par exemple je vais finir faire
une petite faute d'orthographe
j'aime être bon jour avec deux r il me
lemay en surlignage comme ça je me mets
dessus je me fais un petit clic droit et
là ça vient de proposer justement sur
l'orthographe différentes alternatives
donc j'ai
bonjour sans s bonjour avec un dess et à
chaque fois j'ai des déclinaisons le
lira vote
bonjour semblable à salut salutations
révérence alors on peut toujours
commencer vos courriers par référence
salutations hockey révérence cher
monsieur vous paie des révérences bon ok
ce qu'on voit en tout cas ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça viens vous
apporter des solutions alternatives dans
vos courriers fans à éviter que vous
utilisiez toujours les mêmes mots ça
vient enrichir certains jouent donc un
rôle de correcteur orthographique ça
vient aussi arriver au niveau de la
grammaire au niveau de la conjugaison
une petite astuce est aussi très
pratique à ce que tu es en train de
travailler de faire une petite phrase
par exemple allez hop là abonnez vous
les loups vous venez faire un petit clic
dessus ça vous affiche vos options de
mise en page dessus c'est extrêmement
pratique ça vous évite dans l'hérault et
c'est en ça que cette solution est
pratique parce que c'est très rapide
vous êtes toujours dessus ça vient vous
aider ça vient vous corriger ça va me
permettre d'aller plus loin et de sortir
des courriers professionnelle et sans
faute donc ça s'est vraiment bien là je
vous montre en français mais vous avez
des suggestions dans 20 langues donc si
vous devez écrire un courrier en anglais
eh bien ça viendra vous aider pour
enrichir votre vocabulaire en termes de
conjugaison grammaire de ponctuation
donc ça c'est plutôt cool côté
productivité vous avez un cloud qui
aussi un incontournable de microsoft 365
épousé pouvoir avoir votre courrier vos
emails qui sont gérés directement là
vous allez avoir également votre agenda
soit un agenda professionnel que ce soit
un agenda personnel peut même fusionner
les deux vous allez retrouver également
ici tous vos contacts
ici tout est blanc parce que je vous ai
pas afficher toutes les informations de
monsieur heureux mais en tout cas c'est
très facile pour naviguer vous avez
toutes les parties en bas et vous avez
ensuite accès à vos tâches peut devenir
complètement vous organisés entre les
tâches que vous donnez à faire entre
votre emploi du temps avec vos emails
avec vos contacts vous avez tout ça en
un seul et même endroit
c'est très pratique quand logiciel qui
est extrêmement important et non des
moins c'est excellent allant mois
excellent j'utilise pour venir suivre ma
comptabilité quotidienne
je suis tout en dessus vous n'êtes pas
afficher ma comptabilité je pense que ça
vous intéresserait pas il ya pas trop
d'intérêt mais voyez par exemple vous
venez marquer monsieur bisou qui vous a
donné
20 euros vous avez madame joie qui vous
a donné à 10 euros vous voulez faire
ensuite un petit total ici vous devez
faire une somme globale
or pour venir gérer la comptabilité
quotidienne c'est très facile à fait ça
avec les entrées et les sorties vous par
exemple vous avez remboursé 10 euros à
monsieur bisous et vous avez également
donné j'en sais rien moi à 30 euros à
madame joie est bien là haut up de la
même manière vous faites petites sommes
vous voyez vous en êtes et ensuite vous
faites une balance dans la colonne d'à
côté vous voulez savoir où est-ce que
vous en êtes par rapport à ça eh bien
vous cliquez là vous faites la somme des
2 et y voyez vous est déficitaire de 10
euros alors on peut soutenir une petite
comptabilité extrêmement facile à la
maison et là je monte un truc très très
basique sur excel mais vous pouvez aller
beaucoup plus loin termes de mise en
page 2 formules de données bon après je
vous laisserai aller plus loin vous par
rapport à vos besoins mais en tout cas
comme il est là un mois excellent c'est
quelque chose que j'utilise au quotidien
et que je trouve vraiment mais vraiment
extrêmement pratique que vous soyez
professionnel que vous soyez étudiant il
ya aussi un logiciel qui est un
incontournable chez microsoft 160
microsoft 365 c'est dur à dire que c'est
ce soit et bien c'est powerpoint pour me
refaire vos présentations présentation
je pense notamment lorsque vous passez
devant un jury que vous devez valider un
diplôme vous faites votre première salle
est ici ajoute un titre coucou le jury
voulait rajouter des titres des sous
titres clic droit ici vous venez
résultats des diapositives vous en été
autant vous voulez un très beau mais
aussi une mise en page c'est vraiment
très très très très pratique quelles que
soient les présentations que vous allez
faire et ce dont vous avez besoin vous
allez dans conception ça va vous
proposer des mises en page avec des
typos il ya tout un univers qui
s'ouvrent à vous et je trouve qu'on peut
vraiment faire des présentations quel
que soit votre domaine que ce soit je
vous dis une fois de plus pour du pro ou
pour vous dans le cadre de vos études ou
même pourquoi pas faire un truc en
famille j'en sais absolument rien c'est
très facile c'est très simple vous avez
accès à plus de 200 modèles que ce soit
sur word powerpoint excel pas moins de
8000 images 175 vidéo 300 nouvelles
polices et 2800 nouvelle icône autre
point et non des moindres pour venir
naviguer sur internet vous avez le
navigateur microsoft edge bon c'est un
navigateur tout cela est plus simple
vous allez pouvoir ajouter 10
l'extension moi je vous ai mis microsoft
editor ici les points positifs que vous
ai cités dans l'éditeur de world vous
les retrouvez ici notre navigateur
internet que ce soit pour vous pour
faire beau courrier pour travailler pour
de la productivité que ce soit dans le
cadre de vos études de votre gestion
familiale ou même professionnel après
tout ce sont des outils qui sont
performants complet transversaux je sais
pas si vous les utilisez moi
personnellement qu'il ya des outils que
j'utilise énormément de vous le dire
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire qu'est ce que vous pensez
déjà dû aux normes dealbook 14
qu'est ce que vous pensez de microsoft
365 quels outils vous utilisez de
microsoft 165 et quel outil pourrait
vous intéresser par rapport à ce que je
vous ai montré ici dans cette vidéo
marqué matos a bien évidemment en bas en
commentaire à noter que vous avez une
version du magic book 14 qui est
disponible avec microsoft 365 inclus
vous aimez les liens en bas dans la
description pour trouver le meilleur
tarif j'espère que sa tentation vous
auront été utiles sur se donnent rendez
vous extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer à parler texte vous embrasse a
demandé m
[Musique]
forget you lie